my name is Susan Aikens and I'm a kavik
River Camp which is located at sixty
nine point four North by one forty six
point five four west on the Alaska and
North Slope it's like a
bed-and-breakfast just a really an equal
this particular configuration for this
camp was brought out about 25 years ago
by roellig on and vehicles of that
nature like the Nodwell and for the
purpose of just what you see here now it
hasn't changed purpose support for the
oil and gas industry and anybody who
wants to adventure in the Arctic okay in
the winter any the these trailers are
from the 60s and you get enough wind
blowing and you know I mean I get
hurricane-force winds hundred mile an
hour winds out here rocks these babies
so anyway there's a whole the super
supers help them find snow bits is so
the trick for me to get in let's go
getting it out these are a little
outdated like I say the flu sixties but
just because something's old doesn't
mean you throw it away you just
repurpose that this is the women's
shower house my personal favorite I had
been here I don't know maybe eight years
chicks dig baths and I'd been eight or
ten years without a bath
so I created one that was a birthday
present than myself on you
I want a bathtub shipped up is not
something easy to do but this is called
commonly called a fish tote this is a
small one and I gotten supplies in it at
one point and thought oh my gosh I know
how to throw the little haul put a drain
in there and hooked it into the system
mounting cold running water now I have
the ability to take a bath
I only take one I give myself one maybe
two baths a year because it's a lot of
water and I'm always in conservation
mode during the normal season I mean
yeah you want to have running water I
can shower and then do shower all the
times but three months and I
you